we wondered whether it was coming and it
has Donald Trump has been unbanned from
Twitter but as of this moment he hasn't
posted a damn thing and recently said
that he did not plan to return to
Twitter even if he was unbanned uh NPR
reporting on this Elon Musk allows
Donald Trump back on Twitter now what
Elon Musk did was he put out a tweet and
he said should I reinstate Trump to
Twitter
and despite all the claims about how
much of a left-wing Echo chamber Twitter
is and how it's all radical left Bots uh
the yes reinstate votes won on Twitter
claiming that he was representing the
will of the people Elon Musk then went
and had Donald Trump unbanned a quick
look at Donald Trump's Twitter account
shows that his most recent tweet
was uh almost two years old January 8
2021 where he said to all of those who
have asked I will not be going to the
inauguration
on January 20th and of course he did not
go to the inauguration of Joe Biden he
left Washington DC before that the one
listen I don't know whether Trump's
going to come back to Twitter quite
frankly I don't care there's a couple
interesting things here number one
this decision by Elon Musk could torpedo
truth social
and the reason why is as follows
Trump has said I'm not going back on
Twitter truth social is the place where
everything is happening and Trump is in
the middle of trying to uh sell or raise
money for truth social to the tune of
hundreds of millions because truth
social is going down in flames
even if Trump doesn't go back on Twitter
it's harder to imagine that investors
would be as interested in truth social
given that one of the main reasons for
its existence and creation was that
Trump was banned from Twitter so we'll
see how that shakes out and it would be
interesting if this decision by musk
ends up torpedoing torpedoing truth
social the other thing is that Elon Musk
has of course seemingly gone back on his
own word Elon Musk at the end of October
said he is not going to be unbanning any
accounts until a new content moderation
Council forms
we are not aware of such a council
forming and so big shocker Elon Musk
seems to have gone back on his own word
unbanning Donald Trump on the say-so of
his own followers rather than because of
this content moderation Council Will
trump ultimately be able to resist going
back on Twitter I have no idea let me
know what you think I think it's totally
plausible Trump stays off of it I think
it's also totally plausible that if
indeed his campaign continues to not get
the attention that Trump wanted to get
he will get desperate and try to find a
way to get more attention and maybe
going on Twitter would be exactly that
let me know what you think I love
cooking at home I cook all the time
having a good set of knives that you
actually like to use is really important
for years I have been a fan of the
advantages that Japanese knives offer
and our sponsor kamikodo makes amazing
Japanese steel kitchen knives using the
traditional techniques that date back to
the Edo period of Japan kamikoto only
uses steel from Japan each blade takes
years to craft and goes through a
rigorous 19-step inspection process with
a lifetime guarantee the knives come in
a beautiful heavy duty Ash wood box
makes it a really great gift easy to
store as well on the kamikota website
you can see a map of the Michelin star
chefs all over the world using kamikoto
knives my kamikoto knives at home have
been performing great for years you
really just can't beat the feel of a
nice Japanese knife perfectly balanced
in your hand and kamikoto is now running
a big Black Friday sale my audience gets
an extra fifty dollars off go to
kamikodo.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below